were you nervous coming here today
I didn't know how in depth we were going
to go if I knew the questions I don't
think go to slept last night but you
were pathological liar Billy McFarland
he is the band behind the infamous fire
Festival Island Getaway turned disaster
for fire Festival is the subject of two
documentaries I will never forget when
did you realize
so wrong we were at the point where the
timeline I had come up with was just so
off I'd wake up some days it's like we
need four million dollars by 2PM did no
one say to you this is [ __ ] craziness
I just didn't have the ability to like
okay like what's actually happening how
can we prevent this and like almost like
as if On Cue
a storm rolls in Billy McFarland pleaded
guilty to fraud charges sentenced to six
years in prison you come back to a
shitstorm yeah the criminality doesn't
stop though does it but I couldn't like
really understand the magnitude and the
gravity of the crime they did commit
your lawyers tried to get you off the
20-year prison sentence by saying that
you suffered from untreated bipolar
disorder do you have bipolar disorder
um
I did two cents in solitary the seven
month stint was because I tried to do a
podcast over at the Payphone they put
the paperwork in to send me to like a
terrorist facility when you're rendered
useless and Powerless bat just kind of
kills your Humanity that's [ __ ] scary
that keeps me up at night
Andy King
did you ask him to suck a penis here's
what actually happened
before this episode starts I have a
small favor to ask from you two months
ago 74 of people that watch this channel
didn't subscribe we're now down to 69 my
goal is 50 so if you've ever liked any
of the videos we've posted if you like
this channel can you do me a quick favor
and hit the Subscribe button it helps
this channel more than you know and the
bigger the channel gets as you've seen
the bigger the guests get thank you and
enjoy this episode
foreign
[Music]
how are you doing it's been crazy uh
a little less than three and a half
months since my sentence ended
and really just been a whirlwind of
finding the right people finding the
right opportunities
and really just dealing with this
overhang of Probation and the constant
fear that there's someone out there who
could send me back at any time by taking
a wrong turn so
trying to avoid paying people back in
every sense of that word and emotion
while dealing with this fear that I can
wake up one more into a phone call
saying ha like joke's over you're going
back
so take me back um one of the things I'm
so curious about everybody that I sit
here and talk to is their earliest
context in the early start bringing and
how that's like ultimately shaped who
they are today so take me way way back
to New Jersey when you were you know
under the age of 10 what was that what
was your context your parents the the
situation in which you grew up yeah I
grew up in a pretty normal suburban
American household and I think the
defining moment was
when I was 10 years old were I got a
cable internet line into my house and
this was the really early days of the
internet and it was pretty much like the
Wild Wild West era where a lot of like
the framework and Regulation and mature
social platforms that we have now just
didn't exist then we were in the
emphasis of like HTML and CSS and the
practicality and accessibility of some
10 year old putting a website online
and I really found the internet to be
this Outlet where I could push the
boundaries of everything that I thought
was possible as this young Suburban
child and really as a way to start
getting in trouble and seeing what it
was like to get in trouble and see where
I could go
talk to me about your parents I've not
heard um much about them in your
interviews but I'd love to know the
influence they had on you and how that
shaped you I think they're great you
know super loving super supportive and I
think I've been asked this question you
know so many times but whether it's like
the jail therapists like or the
information department and
I think it's interesting that you know
there isn't like a defining moment I
think that kind of set me down like the
entrepreneurial Journey
um
I think I was just like really weird in
this desire to make my own path
and to really test what was possible and
so it's always kind of looking for
Journeys to start businesses and really
like test the bounds of you know of
reality and of the constraints placed on
me at various times in life and
obviously like the constraints of a
ten-year-old are much different than
they were when I was 24 in the midst of
the fire festival and much different at
27 in solitary confinement but I think
the reoccurring theme was trying to find
ways to test those restraints and that
took me to the very best times but also
the very worst times in doing four years
in prison and you know owing the world
whether that's time money friendship and
apology uh so yeah it's been been quite
the journey my question still becomes
like why though so testing the
restraints of like what was possible why
does a kid want to do that like what was
it about about you when you were that
age and your childhood or the
circumstances you found yourself in or
you know what Behavior was being
reinforced and what Behavior was being
punished that made you go off on that
Journey you referenced a sort of a
jailhouse therapist and then probably
asking you these kind of questions as
well yeah did you learn anything about
yourself from that those conversations
totally and
I I think there's always been this
desire to prove that I was different and
I don't think
I really understood like what different
meant I don't think it meant trying to
be like the smartest or the most
interesting I was like trying to prove
that I could create my own path and I
think that's always why been the desire
why did you want to create your empath
and prove that I hear this word proving
a lot throughout your story like a
desire to prove yourself right and prove
yourself to others it comes up over and
over again in the conversations you've
had where did that desire to prove
yourself come from
I think yeah I remember back to like
getting an alpha Smart in you know early
grammar school and I was so desperate to
like hack the teachers like admin
password for the alpha smart to change
the settings on it and just wanted to
show or I think is really proving to
myself that I could do something
different and
I never really did well in terms of like
a structured like learning environment I
was always either like super
disinterested or very very passionate
about something whether it's technology
or computers the Internet and just like
want to dive in and just like almost
testing against myself that I was
possible and what wasn't possible
did those around you like teachers and
your parents have high hopes for you in
your opinion
I think so but they were also you know
I don't want to I don't like the word
like realistic I think they're very like
realistic and structured hopes and my
path was certainly frowned upon by
teachers you know friends uh Etc
throughout the years even when you were
younger people even when I was younger
yeah I think like teachers were always
concerned that like why is he starting a
business and not focusing on his you
know math test so it was it was a
problem since a young age do you
remember getting sort of like critical
or pessimistic feedback at a young age
about your Ambitions and what was
possible for you yeah absolutely and
give me some examples yeah so it's like
uh
I had started a social network a couple
of years later when I was 12 years old
and
this is early days in my space before
Facebook had really gone outside of like
Harvard in the initial Ivy League
schools I created a private Social
Network for my middle school and like
out of nowhere like the site blew up and
you know it was like the talk in middle
school for a few days and the teachers
basically called me in and said like the
internet is not safe you know you have
to stop this right now you have to get
rid of the website and how did that make
you feel
it made me feel like I thought I was
creating something of value but I felt
like that what I viewed as value wasn't
you know agreed upon by everybody else
they'd almost create this like
reinforcement we're like no I know this
is tangible I know this is real and I
know people like are enjoying something
I made and I felt it was just so cool to
have at the time it was hundreds of
people whatever but having hundreds or a
couple thousand people using something I
made as a 12 year old was just really
really interesting to me and I think it
kind of created this
deeper desele and like desire to prove
whether it was to those teachers or to
the friends who like weren't supportive
that there is a different way than you
know the way that we're all taught what
did your parents want you to be you know
like I think my mom wanted me to be I
actually remember my mom's from from
Nigeria she didn't get an education like
uh we do I was born in Botswana in
Africa as well and my mum I think wanted
me to be a doctor or a lawyer okay I
think she was set actually on Doctor
what did your parents want you to be in
your own opinion I don't think they
really cared as long as I followed the
traditional path of like super studying
hard school doing well going to a good
college having a good college experience
I think beyond that
um didn't really care too much I went to
school to study Computer Engineering
didn't last very long so didn't really
you know study Computer Engineering but
that was the uh that was the intent
what's the defining difference between
both of them you know like my mother is
x in terms of characteristics my father
is why what other if you had to describe
them in a couple of words each what
words would you use I think
entrepreneurial uh you know quick like
in terms of like you know quick minds
are sharp they're smart and like honest
I think like Integrity is like the big
thing they're very honest good people
and like that's you know has been part
of the hardest part to me is them and
not just them it's like other family
members and friends trying to understand
how it could go down this path where I
was just lying and you know lying to
investors and partners and employees and
whatever it may have been it's like
understanding how I got there
from you know the the path I had taken
have you had that conversation with them
I have and
it comes down to I think you've you've
nailed it super early on it was just his
desire and I think more than a desire
probably a need to prove myself and fast
forward many many years later with like
fire in the fire Festival that need was
to these these investors who basically
took a chance at me when I first dropped
out of school and had been backing me
for five six seven years before the fire
Festival came to be like
my life I felt and it sounds so silly to
me now but my life I felt to me at that
time was making them happy and making
them money and obviously like the
initial investors if fire didn't work
and didn't work honestly they probably
would have been okay and they would have
been far more understanding than the
fact that I ended up lying at the end to
get their support but it's like need to
prove that I could do it and the ones
who did believe in me the need to prove
that they were right to believe in me
really led me down this terrible
terrible path of however long it was
where I was lying that need to prove
myself
um it can it can go on some fantastic
results in life because you end up
striving and being ambitious and it acts
as a source of motivation but then it
can also
um because I can relate to it it can
also get ugly at some point when that
need overshadows the need to be like
ethical or to even have work-life
balance whatever it might be
have you ever managed in all the time
you've had to reflect on it have you
figured out why you of all people had
that and used the word need not not
desire you you refer to it as a need to
prove yourself like where did that come
from do you do you know I don't know
um
and as I said I've been asked so many
times by people obviously not as smart
as you but I've been asked by a lot of
people and I don't think I've given a
good enough answer and that's probably
something that
I need to think about because it's
dangerous if you you know I'm thinking
about self-awareness here and if that's
still driving you from the back room of
your subconscious
um where that might take you again in
the future right
agree and I think it's more about where
I can find fulfillment and making people
happy because they've made money or
invest in a success
probably is most likely the wrong
formula in a lot of different situations
and I think like especially prison has
made me very very relationship focused
and I feel a stronger need to be trusted
by someone more than to make them happy
and I think that's the furthest area
that I've improved in over the past five
years I've never had you talk about the
um the conversations with your parents
in the wake of everything that happened
and
what what have been those conversations
if I was privy to some of those
conversations in person what would I
have seen
yeah I think I've just
tried to find a way to apologize and
it's been to everybody it's been to
close friends who I think were hurt
emotionally as well other family members
other supporters and it's like trying to
explain to them like why and finding the
real words to apologize
and
it was just so crazy as I've had all
this time to obviously reflect about it
how
I thought I was trying to make people
happy but I was really just like burning
down these relationships and hurting
them along the way and it's just how
messed up that pursuant path really was
have you actually apologized to your
parents oh absolutely yes
and what's their stance been throughout
jail and before and even now how what's
their perspective been
it's been like
close family is different because
obviously we're in touch and you know
everybody
families your family and I think for
like childhood friends who I was
probably closer with like on an
emotional level it's been a little weird
when I essentially was on the sideline
in a way for four years or whatever the
time frame was and then during that time
I'm kind of sheltered from like the
media and the comments and everything
like I don't necessarily hear or even
see everything that's happening and so
like the bulk of that is directed
towards other people like whether it's
family or friends so after so long of
like being The Target just because I'm
not there to be the target they start to
like you know form different opinions
and their minds start to wander and then
I think when I've seen people for the
first time like since jail and then I
can kind of see like a switch flip in
their head after like four or five
minutes like oh okay he's the old Billy
that I used to know and they start like
acting normal again which like really
crazy to me that when I was in jail I
just didn't really understand or
appreciate the terrible [ __ ] basically
that close people to me had to go
through just because I wasn't like
available to
be at the receiving end of everything
that's happened what did they go through
I think like the the emotional trauma
right and people are looking to blame
someone and to you know throw shade and
hate and I deservedly say I want someone
and if I'm not there like to be able to
take that hake some physically locked
away somewhere people need a target for
it and you know unfortunately I think
for a lot of people who and I learned
this in jail too A lot of people in jail
the ones that take it the hardest are
the friends and family is because
they're not the one they're not the
reason why you're there but they suffer
almost the most from it it's just it's
not fair did they tell you that they had
been on the receiving end of that that
abuse yeah and a lot of friends too you
know what what kind of abuse do they
tell you explicitly what kind of abuse
they'd been on the receiving end of
I think it's just like the mental and
it's like emotional anguish
um
I've had like friends even who didn't
work with me but you know who were super
close and around for a lot of the build
up of the events and whether it's from
like their family or their friends or
their employers like how could you not
know how could you have been with him
and
people are looking for I think the
public looks for someone to blame and if
I wasn't there to receive that blame or
wasn't responding to it that blame they
just look for other targets and like
I think that's what crushed me the most
is on this limited contact with friends
or family whatever from jail like
hearing
the sadness and abuse they were taking
and being able to do absolutely nothing
about it just like totally powerless
going back into a story it's you know I
was reading through all of the sort of
entrepreneurial endeavors
you you did as a as a young man even
before the age of like 15 years old
you'd started companies you'd sold
companies
um just just a long long list of
continually starting another business
starting at like nine years old you
started programming 13 you start this um
this this Outsourcing startup which
eventually gets sold on an auction site
called um your hot site I believe and
then at 15 years old you create a
company called 24 scene which is
eventually sold to Buddy TV when you
were 15 years old you go off to you
graduate at 18 from I guess high school
high school yeah we call it different
things in the UK
um you go to university and in your
freshman year you drop out and start a
company called spling and you raise four
hundred thousand dollars in a series a
round for this company called spling at
18 years old right the financing around
today are a little different so this is
this is like 2010 but yeah crazy how the
world's change right yeah yeah so you
raised that Capital at 18 years old yes
is that your first sort of window into
the fact or point of awareness we think
[ __ ] I can raise capital for things that
I have ideas for I think the biggest
thing there was
having someone so much smarter and older
and like more successful than me
actually like believe in me and back it
up
the idea to like any friend in any
family that I'm taking time off school
or dropping out of school was like
totally not okay but the fact that I can
point to like a small group of these
early investors who were clearly like
established and you know
like amazing
almost like icons in their own fields
that was when I was like look I have
this real group who is supporting me
beyond their words and I need to show
not just them but I need to show the
world that these people were right and
everybody else who was saying like what
I'm doing is wrong is incorrect who was
saying you were wrong at that age 18. he
was betting against you I think like
every peer you know all your friends all
the friends all your family members I
think all your family members
at all I think the majority um and I
think that the big thing was like
my friends at that age who especially
like the ones who like did better in
school and you know probably a little
bit smarter
it's just really as much as like they
can't admit it and I know I do this to
other people too so I think I see it as
much as they can't do it like they don't
want to see someone and obviously we're
super young at that age but succeed
Beyond them and it's like hey I'm
studying 70 hours a week you know I know
I'm smarter than he is and I'm working
just as hard or harder than him you know
why can he go and do this and I can't so
I think that's kind of like a a mantra
that you know I've noticed a lot amongst
like close friends and obviously I see
that same behavior in myself so yeah I
think that that bar just sucks on spling
yeah it was an Avenue for you to
eventually move to New York yes what
happened to that company eventually
failed yeah so uh moved to New York
actually in the second ever we work
space in New York uh this is 2011 I
think yeah it's a second ever we work
space in New York and spling starter is
a social network and I was kind of like
parlaying off of what I had built in you
know middle school and high school and
you know had this really small you know
websites that ended up selling which is
great
um the social networking aspect display
never really took off and ended up
making software and started to sell it
to like these record labels and TV
networks and I was like the Suburban kid
who was already weird for programming
and now I'm the Suburban kid who's weird
for programming crazy for dropping out
of school and now I'm sitting in the
office with you know the heads of these
like massive media companies that we've
all heard of that like I didn't even
know really like existed like to go meet
with like the boss at Def Jam or Hearst
or like Discovery or Disney like all
these companies that were just like a
logo on TV for me as a young kid I was
now like tangibly there and they were
like paying for something I was building
it was just a wild experience to go from
you know being in a dorm room in the
middle of nowhere to
in the midst of the entertainment World
in New York and so at some point you
make the decision to close spling down
so spring was going and I just got super
distracted
by these entertainment companies that I
was going to and like I kept trying to
tell back like these childhood friends I
kept trying to explain to them like what
was happening they didn't really believe
me and now it's really the Genesis of
magnesis was that I wanted to take like
the 19 year old me who wasn't working at
spling and give him access to this world
of like entertainment and fashion and
like media that I was like finding
myself stumbling into in New York and so
I'm trying to get to the point of like
there comes a day where you go
I mean I've had this in my life my first
startup yeah as well when I was
literally 18 and then I left it at 20
inside my next business but there's a
day where you go
[ __ ] that I'm gonna do magnesis instead
so I basically said [ __ ] that I'm gonna
do magnesis but like still keeps playing
going so okay yeah so spring now is like
my biggest mistake so explain kept
operating for you know a few years with
let's say 10 to 15 hours of a week of
attention Okay whereas like you know the
vast majority of my time was focused on
magnesis I think like one of the
reoccurring themes is just not seeing
things through and like it happened
again with my nieces into fire but like
jumping ship when
spring would not have been as big as
magnesium or fire could have been but it
still could have it still was okay and
like I could have had a successful exit
for people who were involved and just
like not seeing that through it was just
wrong
reoccurring theme yeah
um I mean I see that throughout your
childhood and then internally into early
sort of twenties yeah that that um that
I guess ambition
and that sort of constant inspiration
you have leads you to kind of abandon
the last thing and and an entrepreneur's
currency is their time and attention so
as you as you cited there it's finite it
means that the old thing gets a fraction
of your time when really if it's going
to succeed in that market it needs more
than all of your time yes um this leads
you on to magnesis in 2013 yeah we
launched 15 2014 eventually yeah
magnesis was a tell me tell me what it
was and why you chose to switch your
attention to this yeah so magnesis was
a network that was seeking to give young
people living in major cities access to
better benefits events and networking
than their like credit card would give
them
so like literally this is 2012 I just I
started doing the magnesis card before
it launched I went in Alibaba this is
like 10 years ago before Alibaba is
Alibaba bought this like blank black
sheet of metal and a Credit Card Copier
and literally went and copied my like
really crappy debit card with 20 onto it
onto this like black metal card and just
like went to the pizza parlor across the
street and the guy just made a total
scene when I went to pay and went and
showed the card off around wework and
started selling cards to like
interesting entrepreneurs at wework and
that was like literally the Genesis of
magnesis and the cool of the proposition
was that it was kind of elite and
exclusive yeah so it was definitely
trying to cater towards this like
upwardly mobile
entrepreneur style crowd
that feels like a through line across
many of your businesses that went on
which was like appealing to people's
desire for
status and clout because when I was
reading about magnesis at the end of the
day it felt like it was a a black metal
card which was again appealing to
people's egos because everybody wants
that American Express black card but
they can't get it because you need to
spend you need to spend like a quarter
of a million to get it yeah so it makes
people feel amazing and then you're
promising them
the application process was only a few
people could apply it was all appealing
to that people's desire to be
that's what it started out when I was
like 19 or 20 whatever the time was and
then it ended up growing and the real
benefit was in network and there were
certain members or card holders who were
meeting other members and kind of giving
them value and I think like the first
concept of magnesis was one I wanted the
black card for sure now it was like the
fun novelty like more of the marketing
aspect of it but two is I wanted like a
vehicle to share and really invite my
friends to all these like Entertainment
Properties where I was starting to
experience and explore because they
didn't believe me so it was almost like
show them what I was telling them was
actually happening and have an excuse to
bring people along through this club or
Community built around magnesis and you
raised capital for magnesium 1.5 million
before you launched and then three point
something off yeah I think that the
total was in like the mid mid threes
yeah so nothing crazy like but okay and
um jar rule comes into the picture
sometime around the magnesis yeah so it
started basically like once again
magnesium is all about One fulfilling
like my fantasies of places I wanted to
go and can get to and then once I was
there having all of my friends come too
and I just like loved hip-hop as a kid
so throughout magnesis we booked
probably close to a dozen and a half or
even like 20 rappers to come perform
these small concerts for magnesis and
that's what started the whole ball
rolling towards like the fire app and
that concept so when did you meet Ja
Rule uh during one of these magnesis
member events and the thing that's
really struck me at the time was how
hard it was to book him
and when he finally like received the
offer he said yes and like almost like
instantly right and the problem was this
like web of
quasi-agents and middle management
managers who all kind of claimed like
represent another talent but in reality
they knew someone who knew like a sister
who knew a brother who knew a cousin and
it's like this terrible
really like opaque nasty world and
coming from like a technology background
it made no sense to me I knew there were
other like kids like me right who would
you know pay something reasonable to get
access to this kind of like music Talent
so we started talking about building an
app which ended up becoming the fire app
to provide like a window into like
entertainers pockets for anybody to give
them offers directly and because of that
experience with Ja Rule and just general
General artist booking that's what that
was the Genesis of this fire app that
was a complete Genesis was like booking
a lot of these rappers through magnesis
realizing that almost every single time
we were going through middlemen who like
weren't really like the the manager of
the agent and then realizing okay I now
had this network of you know 20 artists
and their real managers so I can give
like access to other people through
technology
and from what I was reading
um this is the when one of the first big
lies was told which was around the
success of fire mobile app I read this I
think I can't remember where I saw it
might have been the Hulu documentary or
something it said that an internship to
investors it was claimed to be worth 90
million dollars but was actually doing
60k in business what is the truth around
that where was the where was the LIE
told here yeah so the fire app and the
fire Festival really all come together
at the same time
um
it's crazy to think back like how how
quick I went down a bad path but how
quick everything happened as well during
that time period
this is all 2016. um the fire app was
launched at some point mid-2016 and the
fire Festival was you know conceived in
September October of 2016. so it was all
kind of around the same time Wi-Fi
Festival how did that come to be that
because the fire app came first fire out
came first how did you get from there to
fire Festival so we had a townhouse
space basically this Clubhouse if you
will for magnesis members and one of the
people working at the front desk I lived
a handful of blocks away calls me one
night and says there's this guy here who
is building some crazy things at Google
but he says he flies planes and wants to
fly you I think he's telling the truth
you have to come and meet him so I ran
over the townhouse and met this guy and
like absolute genius like one of the
best
like developers of AI I've ever met in
my life and you know he's going to go on
to I think change your world in very
many ways but he's like listen like I
Fly for Fun I have a bunch of friends
who do the same thing we should take a
few planes and do a trip to the outer
islands of the Bahamas for your
magnesium members so we've been running
these trips for years
and I found these outer Islands to
essentially be this like welcoming
playground where there might be 10
people who live on the island who are
just like so amazing and kind-hearted
and warm and once you bring 18 20 24
people there from New York everybody
kind of drops like their pretense and if
you connect them around these like
almost like life-defying experiences and
Adventures they really really come
together so it was running these trips
for a number of years when I literally
brought like one of these childhood
friends that I mentioned and fire app
had just launched he said hey man you
should totally do a music festival here
for all magnesis members so that was the
real person who came up with the idea
and that's how the fire Festival
happened and when was where was the the
first light holding yeah in the
fundraising process was it on raising
capital for the app was it capsule for
the magnesis yeah so the the fire
um
the fire Festival app didn't raise much
money prior to like the festival
announcement
we came up with a festival idea in
September of 2016.
shot and released at promotional video I
think a lot of people saw in December of
2016 and announced a April of 2017 like
launch date so the period was super
super short so somewhere in like the
weeks leading up to that December
promotional video I started lying and
that was lying to Fire apps investors
lying to fire festivals investors lying
about magnesius's numbers it all kind of
hit when
oh [ __ ] fire Festival is real we're
announcing a festival we have X number
of months to build a city in the middle
of nowhere how the [ __ ] are we gonna do
this that's just like set me off down
that that path
from
I think from what I recall there was
four months between you announcing the
festival and the festival happening so
you're going to the middle of nowhere
you've got to build sewage yeah
infrastructure basically a city from
scratch at 25 years old with
out the capital to do it and without the
experience in doing it in
four months in 120 days so stupid
so bad
I think I I got my 25th birthday we
launched the trailer for The Fire
Festival
and I still didn't think it was real at
that time like we had these great trips
with a few dozen people and those we
could totally handle we launched a
trailer then I remember waking up like
you know quasi hung over five or six
hours later and we'd sold like a half
million dollars to tickets if I said
that to people now in my team and you
know I've you know I'm I'm 30 now same
age as you yeah um you know I've got
huge amounts of resources in terms of
like contacts and capital everyone in my
team would turn around to me and give me
that look and say this is not possible
Stephen
did people say that to you
did no one say to you this is [ __ ]
craziness absolutely and I think that
part of the curse and and part of the
gift at the time was
a lot of their reasons that were being
given to me by things were impossible
we're all solved with these short-term
Miracles and of course everybody said
hey the end goal is impossible you're a
[ __ ] like you don't understand like
what this takes
and then they would give three or four
reasons about like smaller problems
right and then I would go and like
create Magic and solve these three or
four problems and be like look we've
proved that like we can handle the
bigger stuff too and I think it just
took
so many random like rolls of the dice to
go our way to be able to create a
failure so large because if we found
like a stumbling block or a roadblock
earlier on it would have stopped the
whole thing but it was like this weird
combination of
smart crazy people all kind of coming
together for this wild idea and solving
things we should never been able to
solve until we couldn't
lying plays a big role in that though
100 I think you have to add line to the
mix because I don't think he would have
gotten those people to that Island on
that plane without a series of
almost like nuns stop lying there's no
way that you would have well in my view
um if people knew the reality of my view
if people knew the reality of the
numbers and the situation on the ground
and I remember watching the
documentaries which I know you haven't
seen yeah still no yeah we're going to
talk about that but I remember seeing
the there were moments where you were
saying to team members don't don't tell
this investor the nature of the
situation and had you been honest I
think investors from my experience of
building companies would not have backed
this the reality of the situation if if
they knew the truth they wouldn't have
backed that agree
I always think that like lying hurt
things the most
they lying
really pushed away the help that I
needed and I think that how we just
announced the festival with our trailer
video
we had already proven our ability to you
know create hype to bring a manageable
number of people to these islands to
give them like an amazing experience
if I just like threw my like hands up
the next day and said okay I didn't
expect to sell this many tickets and I
don't have the resources or or like
wherewithal to actually execute this now
I think the professionals would have
flocked to me and said okay like we are
experts in doing this like let us take
over and you do what you're good at but
like let us you know be the adults in
the room and make this thing actually
happen and why didn't you put your hands
up and say that I I that's like a type
of lawsuit over the past five years but
that's where we're like Beyond lying
like breaking all the ethics and morals
which like totally didn't totally wrong
it pushed away to help
are you a pathological liar
this is a claim that I've I've heard
leveled at you by the judge in your case
by other people that were working on
fire Festival
um people in the documentaries
yeah I think like my entire
Mantra and drive right now is to form
like super super close relationships and
I want those six or eight people
to never question my integrity and I
think like getting on a microphone and
telling the world hey guys like I'm not
a pathological liar he's like yeah shut
the [ __ ] up but it's like I want to feel
Pride where I can like go home tonight
and I know like these six to eight
people that I can call or they can call
me you know we will have our backs and I
really don't have the answer in terms of
like how I adjust it to the world but
it's like the six to eight people and
you guys know who you are like
let's build that trust because that's
one of the even when I was thinking
about doing this interview obviously you
know the foundation of the Diary of SEO
is honesty yeah and I'm thinking after
all this stuff I've seen in these
documentaries how do I know that he's
not just going to come here and [ __ ]
me yeah how do I know that I'm not going
to be one of the investors or one of the
other people that was was lied to how do
I know he's going to give me the truth
yeah
how do you receive that
it's just so hard to hear like it's it's
super hard to hear and I think like
natural reaction is to always like fight
back and argue oh I'm not a lie of then
you just like and it's just like
digs you down
a further hole
so I think it's just finding pride in a
different area and it's like I am highly
flawed and like any claims made to the
contrary are just are wrong and for
whatever good ideas I've had I've had
you know 10 times many bad ones and like
clearly I Allied to an extent that
I would really hope that the vast
majority of the population like would
never be comfortable doing so yeah I
highly highly flawed and I think like
the next 30 years of my life will be
defined by can I focus on my skill set
can I be honest with a small number of
people around me and like can I get help
in those areas where I clearly need it
as you know Intel are now sponsoring
this podcast and last week I introduced
you to Intel Evo platform the badge of
approval for high spec laptops that pass
Intel Zone strip requirements and enable
you to be more productive on the go as
someone who spends most of their life on
the go it's Intel Eva that really caught
my eye when we were discussing this
partnership the idea that Intel gives
your laptop the seal of approval for you
on all things like all-day battery life
fast charging and high performance makes
my life easier when I'm buying a new
laptop because I know that if it's got
that Intel seal of approval then it's
going to be able to keep up with me
they've basically done all the hard work
and research for you and confirmed it's
going to be able to keep up with your
busy life on the go head to intel.co.uk
EVO to find out more about the televo
platform also for a limited time you you
can currently get 15 off all Intel Evo
devices at John lewis.com the code is
Evo ceo15 that's
e-v-o-c-e-o15 until December 11th so
head over to John lewis.com to check out
the intelivo designs and get your 15 off
terms and conditions apply see more
details in the description box
for many years people have been asking
for a coffee flavored Hill and quite
recently he'll release the iced coffee
caramel flavor of their
um ready to drink Hills and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
heels ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about your you haven't watched
the documentaries no
the first prison I was at or like when
they appeared when they came out the uh
the guys got like a USB stick with both
the documentaries and watched them and I
was like I literally went outside I
think I was like one of two people who
wasn't in the TV room watching the
documentary but couldn't do it why
I think at that time
I was still like this is early 2019 so I
was less than a year into my sentence I
think I was still like in the combative
phase where I just hadn't like come to
reality with everything that happened
and I was too scared to hear allegations
or comments by other people and not be
able to respond and I like realized like
being locked up
and then having someone say something
where it's probably like 70 true and 30
false I wouldn't have like focused on or
internalized the part that was true even
though that was probably most of it I
just would have gotten enraged by the
false part but I wouldn't be able to do
anything about it so I felt like if I
was not like stable enough or mature
enough
at that time to to watch it and I
probably still I'm not but really yeah
because I was gonna ask you to follow up
was why haven't you watched them now
then if that was 2019 in 2022 now so why
haven't you watched them still so I
caught myself the other day someone
asked me the same question and I said
and I think this show is like I'm not
like mature enough to watch it yet I
said no one in this is probably slightly
true but exaggerated I said no one real
interviewed for the documentary like why
would any business person who has
anything going on in their life you know
attach themselves to the event that's
mostly true obviously but but still some
of the people who did interview I'm sure
were you know sharing real stories of
real things that happened so I'm just
I'm not ready there's no way I don't
know why but I'm not ready
because of how it might make you it
might trigger you in some type of way or
I think so and yeah I just I did ask
myself I said would you if that happened
to me when I watched the documentaries
and I'm gonna be honest I don't know
yeah I don't know but you must
everywhere you go now have
piece together those documentaries
because people like me ask you seven
questions for sure
unfortunately I think I've heard more
than than I wanted to but I think I
understand
how do you feel about the fact that like
probably for at least some time now the
center point of conversations you have
and interviews you do is going to Center
on
that that's gonna like that's gonna be a
real defining thing for for many that
meet you I think it's super interesting
like
think about personally and it's almost
like weird because a lot of the people
who have watched documentary whether
they're friends or family members other
people
their advice is like you are incompetent
you can't do anything going forward like
you know go work some entry level like
desk job for 70 hours a week for the
rest of your life and and shut up and I
think it's kind of like ironic right
because then you're stuck living with
the remorse the guilt the failure of
what you did before and I think the
other option is
can I go about it but go for it and go
for it honestly and if I fail it's okay
but you know at least take the swing and
like which path would you know make you
prouder and I've chosen the latter which
might be right it might be wrong but I
just think it's really weird to me how a
lot of like the close friends who have
watched a documentary almost all their
advice have just been like you can't do
anything now and maybe they're right but
it's like that's been like I think
that's the hardest thing to internalize
from the whole
like after effect process where we
currently stand
well you've clearly got a
internal bias to just prove everybody
wrong which doesn't seem to have left
you right so when you hear that the
Billy that I mean I've come to learn in
the last you know couple of minutes
speaking together with just 100 use that
as fuel right I think like
I find Pride differently now and when
you're locked away for four years and
ten months like when you're alone or
with a cellmate but like in solitary
confinement you can't leave you have to
find pride in like the littlest and
weirdest things and you know once you
leave 95 of it it's just like irrelevant
and gets out the window but I think like
finding pride is where it stands and
do I want to be the the guy who's honest
but quit or the guy who's honest but
went for it and then whatever the
outcome is the outcome is and like to me
I can find more pride in that path
fire Festival you raise more than 20
million dollars
now that alone is not an easy thing to
do
you know lying yeah definitely aided
that for 100 but even if people were
lying even if someone was just purely
lying there's still an element of
salesmanship that goes into
accomplishing such a big investment
raise for a first-time Music Festival
when you're 25 years old
what are your skill sets that that made
that happen let's just lying it we put
that on the table you lied yeah but what
are the other skill sets that
enabled that massive failure
so I think it's like taking a second to
like dive into the lies and why it was
so bad I think there's like a
misconception at least from what I've
heard that I woke up one day made a fake
spreadsheet which is totally true and
then with that spreadsheet you know went
and raised a bunch of money I think the
reality is it's like not that simple you
know I can make a bad spreadsheet
tomorrow without my background and
you're just not going to go and raise 20
million dollars straight it's like it
doesn't go like that
I think the hardest part is a trust is
that the majority of the people who are
backing me
had either invested in me since I was 19
years old or I'd see me work since I was
19 or were you know referred or trusted
someone like who fell into one of those
camps so it was like six years of
trust and failure and struggle that I
had to go through to get to the position
where I could even ask for that kind of
money so more than the lie but the
revenue at the time which I almost think
is not as bad as betraying the trust of
the years it took to get to that point
where I was even in the position to lie
about the revenue
so there's that trust building which
again the jury's probably out on whether
that trust was built honestly yeah
because you talked about
magnesis also being inflated in terms of
the numbers they're being lies there but
then your personal skill like what is it
in hindsight you think why did these
people
back me as an individual what are your
skill sets like Charisma or is it your
ability to talk your communication
skills what was it I almost think that
you could find
similarities in these early trips that
led to the fire Festival in some of the
magnesis experiences which
is taking people who wouldn't usually
meet bringing them together and then
taking them to a place
they've never been before whether that's
like
a jet ski race at midnight around these
like uninhabited islands or like spear
fishing for your own Lobster with
someone you've always wanted to meet
it's about just like connecting
interesting people with like a tinge of
crazy around these adventures and like
those Adventures could be physical it
could be virtual but that's kind of
always been I think what is intrigued
backer someone that's a friend a partner
a sponsor an investor is to be part of
that
you know tornado of activity and
connection and excitement interesting so
the people so what I got from that is
the people that invested in you wanted
the same thing as the people that bought
tickets to fire Festival they wanted to
be part of something really really cool
themselves they wanted to meet
interesting people and do interesting
crazy [ __ ] like that's like that's the
ammo and you ended up selling some 8 000
tickets for two weekends at fire
Festival yeah
I mean everyone remembers the orange
tile campaign and the use of influencers
and we had Kendall Jenner Bella Hadid
Haley Baldwin Emily ratatowski and you
shot this in this promo video
um in the Bahamas which became pretty
viral because no one had ever seen that
group of influences together before yeah
um
at that point you know you know you know
two months three months out from the
festival you've sold these [ __ ]
tickets this is when the lies get really
bad out there like in one of the
documentaries it says that you put a
villa up on the site for a quarter of a
million to try and raise some money that
you didn't have
um and then I read further and further
and I was trying to understand the world
you were in that was causing you to
continually lie and lie and lie and I
heard about this urgent payment sheet
what was this urgent payment shame how
is that driving you we were at the point
where the timeline that
I had come up with it was just so off
and ridiculous
it just like made all the payments and
vendors just kind of go through the roof
in terms like the cost to make something
happen so quickly and like we just had
no money right we were just trying to
get money from any Source whether it was
investors or sponsors or customers or
ticket sales consulting jobs I was like
you know wearing 10 hats to trying to
get the income we needed to fund the
fire Festival
and
the money crunch was so bad I'd
literally wake up every day you know at
9am to a sheet where we had a list of
every payment we had to make before the
bank wire cut off at four o'clock that
day so I knew that by 2 pm I'd have that
money come into our account is the team
had enough time to wire it out before
the four o'clock wire deadline and so
I'd wake up some days it's like we need
four million dollars by 2PM so I'd have
five hours to go out Source the
investors
come to terms with them and actually get
the money in the account or else people
are dead in the water four million yeah
we managed to survive like this for
almost 60 days and some days it was 100
Grand and some days it was four million
dollars but like it was it was Wild on
that day that it was four million
dollars you got till 2PM
what'd you do start started calling
investors and saying well I think like
I was telling them we were [ __ ] unless
we had this money and I think that like
a lot of the investors almost adapted
a similar mindset to me that we're in so
far that hey we've already spent X
what's an extra couple million dollars
at this point because if this thing
works we're all going to make money
and that was the that was the mindset
that I was trying to build and I truly
believed obviously it was so silly now
to look back on because one of the in
one of the documentaries they paid they
paint the opposite picture they say that
you were calling investors and not
telling them the extent of how bad
things were because yeah there was one
particular moment where you'd sent an
email telling someone not to tell the
investor the true nature of the
situation with the accommodation because
they wouldn't give more money so the
documentary tells a completely different
story about being opaque yeah
untransparent to investors in those
crunch moments I think like one of the
bad thing is is I definitely sheltered
information like not every investor
would have the same information not
every team member of the same
information so I certainly kept
a lot of the logistical problems in the
dark
but if I knew like one investor could
solve this problem you know I would tell
them about the logistics problem
but then say don't tell anybody else but
we need your help here so I was picking
and choosing people who I thought would
be sympathetic or capable of handling
certain situations so I mean terrible
approach but it was like a mix of hey
we're in this far we need a little bit
more so give it to us and also a mix of
well we can't tell everybody this
because if people realize you know we
need
four million dollars by two o'clock
today we sound crazy and we're dead
people hearing that situation where you
have this urgent payment sheet and
you're waking up in the morning and it
says 100K on it 250k yeah um four
million yeah
um one of the things in the documentary
showed that you were
popping up like fake Villas and stuff
like that to meet the debt owed on that
payment sheet so if you owed if you
needed 50k that day pop a villa online
call it the Dolphin Villa sell it for
50k and that would cover the decision is
that true I don't think it was as one to
one as that right um
we certainly were trying to sell as many
expensive ticket packages possible that
didn't exist that whether it was like
boats or Yachts that like you know we
would go in Charter or whether it was
like high-end Villas that we were trying
to rent but they didn't have them at the
time
so I think our numbers were not like one
to one at the end of the day however we
did rent a couple hundred Villas so I
know I've heard so many conflicting like
stories from this but you know we did
rent a couple hundred Villas and uh I'm
sure we were off by a number but it
wasn't like hey we had no Villas on the
island there was a quarter million
dollar package for like a villa or a
yacht or something yeah did that sell
um I think we sold a couple couple boats
for like in that range quarter million
dollars and then we had there was a
couple houses in the island which were
like these like 10 bedroom you know like
private estate type things we sold a
number of them I don't think it was like
it wasn't tons but we sold a couple well
the boats did the boats exist yeah on
the day we partnered with like basically
like this like yacht brokerage company
so we would just like ride it through
there
and as the so going back to my point
about that urgent payment sheet you just
said that you'd wake up like yeah wake
up on days look at the Urgent payment
sheet that you should you'd be like oh
[ __ ]
now I've I've sat here with um the CEO
of one of the disruptor banks out in
Europe called Tom monzo and he talked
about the like mental torment he had a a
red phone by his bed he's running a bank
here yeah so he'd wake up every day and
he'd have a moment of like Dread waking
up because
the stress and the pressure of you know
having to run a bank when you're waking
up one of those days yeah what is the
like the mental health implication what
did you feel
it was awful and I think
the one benefit and detriment that I had
was an end date like this is all going
to end on whether right or wrong like on
the Festival date right where they're
going to succeed and like be Champions
or we're gonna drastically fail and
either way like let's go all in to try
to make that happen
and what was the you say the word awful
take me into the world's word awful give
me a description of what that actually
means in reality what are the symptoms
of that I mean I was fat as [ __ ] like my
heart was out of rhythm you know your
heart was out of rhythm yeah like I
think like
lost interest in
sexual relationships lost interest in
like friendship relationships that
weren't transactional and it became like
all work and nothing else mattered I'm
like look terrible felt terrible and I
could just it sucks and I can't imagine
like the red phone at the bank because
like that's never ending right like
maybe you can say Hey you know I'll sell
or hire a new CEO in seven years but I
can't imagine like that kind of window I
would yeah well he ultimately quit after
seven years building out of business I
think it was valued a billion billions
when he quit and when he did a piece in
one of the newspapers he cited his
mental health
um yeah did you experience anxiety
for sure
um
I was I was afraid to show weakness
right so it's like
I didn't acknowledge it to myself I
certainly didn't acknowledge it to
anybody else but like I knew something
was wrong I shouldn't be 24 and my
heart's skipping beats like you know
that's not not normal there's no reason
why that should be happening but um yeah
I just refuse to acknowledge it and like
would tell myself you're just soft like
plenty of people have had to live with
like much worse stress in this
figure it out suck it up do you know
that feeling of anxiety the one I'm
talking about where it's it's like
constant state for sure and you
experience you were experiencing that in
the lead-up to the festival absolutely
how badly
it was bad
and yeah I mean like looking back it's
crazy like no one wants to live right
with a dread to wake up every morning
not knowing like what that Excel
document's gonna be and then who I have
to beg or call or plead or sell to to
solve that problem it just a shitty life
but you you thought you were in too deep
and you couldn't turn back yeah I
thought that like
I wrongly convinced myself that there
was an end goal and there was a solution
like if the event worked and it went
well we'd have a great brand and
everybody's happy everybody makes money
everybody's gonna want to come next year
and obviously it was so stupid silly but
that was a pure
I had to finish line in sight
when did you realize
it had all gone wrong yeah the night
before the so the festival was scheduled
to be Friday Saturday and Sunday for two
weekends
um we had a charter to 737 planes and
open up like a temporary terminal in
Miami to basically fly everybody to the
island and given we only had two planes
we started to fly guests in early on a
Thursday morning before like before the
festival started on Friday and late that
Wednesday night we were like rushing to
get everything ready in time
and it's like walked into the room
around midnight and like the entire team
was like slumped over on their chairs
like asleep on the couch like heads like
leaning on the kitchen table
and it seemed like all the energy at the
same time but it's like left the entire
team
and like almost like as if On Cue as
I've written by a movie a storm rolls in
like late that Wednesday and then it's
like oh [ __ ] like I've lost a team
you can't beat the weather like or we're
not in a good spot
thinking back to the promo um video that
you made and comment you made on the
full send podcast about how the guy that
buys the yachts and gets all the girls
to come and then pays for it subsidizes
it is never a happy man yep
um are you this was the question I was
putting as I was reading about your
story is like what are your insecurities
because a lot of this seems to be driven
by some kind of like deep insecurity to
like prove the prove others right to be
the man to be the guy to throw the best
party and the validation on a
psychological level that must be giving
some kind of insecurity some whole it
must be filling for sure yeah what are
your insecurities
and what were they
good question yeah
yeah this I think the need it always
kind of came back the need to prove
this path right of like I don't need
school I don't need the path that we
were all taught as a right path like my
path is better and it leads to more
interesting and more exciting life and
like I think I always knew that but I
was so insecure and I wanted to have
everybody else believe it and I would
get frustrated when people didn't share
those same beliefs as me
so I think it's been part of the
learning process as well is to
understand that everybody can't believe
and like the same thing and that's okay
and like not taking it personally when
that happens
have you got any insecurities around
women
I don't know yeah yeah
it just seems to be centered on this
desire to like prove everybody wrong and
like [ __ ] the system yeah
um
I still I'm still not quite clear in my
mind where that where that came from I'm
like was he bullied in school was it was
there a teacher that said some [ __ ] to
him that he couldn't do it was his
parents told him he couldn't do it I
think part of it is like the curse of
of things never being enough right and I
guess I don't know what the derivation
of that is but
you know whether it's business success
or friendship success
where you live your home your
possessions like your the love that
someone has for you
especially during that time of my life I
was almost like jaded into always
thinking that it wasn't enough like if
someone loved me they didn't love me
enough or if like I had a great like day
at work the day wasn't good enough and I
think it all kind of come back to like
maybe I'm thinking out loud here maybe
it was like the early exposure at like
18 and 19 to like Titans of industry and
then me comparing to them where it's
like not feasible to get there without
you know 20 30 40 years of work that
they had put in but it's like I wanted
everything at that level and I wanted it
now so if you gave me this much but it
wasn't like where they were I wasn't
satisfied with it so I think it was like
the early exposure
combined with like the impatience and
need to have it there's this really um
well publicized scene where you're stood
on a crate on the day of the festival
you've got all of these party goers
around you kind of screaming and asking
questions and some of them a little bit
drunk because they've been off yeah sent
to a bar on the other side of the island
when you're trying to sort of buy
yourself time
what was going on when you were still in
that crate and what were you thinking
and feeling were you [ __ ] yourself I
mean right now I realized like how bad
my management skills were at the time
like where the [ __ ] is everybody like we
had they weren't all full-time employees
a lot of them were like local
contractors or whatever we had almost
800 people you know the day of the
festival like working there I just felt
like I was surrounded by these people
I couldn't find any of my team members
and I had I'm not going to name the
publication I had a publication on the
phone with me saying you know we heard
you ran off on your yacht with like
cocaine and hookers like I don't have a
yacht never done cocaine like there were
no hookers and but they're also live
streaming on the on the cover of their
web page so I'm like yelling at them I'm
getting yelled at by like you know the
50 or 100 concert goers right there I
just couldn't find anybody but just goes
to show I just like didn't have the
systems in place to or the knowledge to
manage everything but that was my first
reaction is like where the hell is
everybody
I heard you made the decision to cancel
the festival when someone incorrectly
told you that people had died yeah I was
told
shortly after that moment maybe an hour
or two later that three people had died
and thankfully no one was physically
hurt like at all to my knowledge but I
was told these elaborate stories who
told you that uh team members and place
and I think the reality was looking back
now is that concert goers were like
reading things on Twitter and then
coming running to employees and telling
them this but like verified Twitter
accounts is back in what 17 were like
nothing like gunshots fire like people
hit like it was going all over Twitter
and people were getting shot and things
like that and like none of this was true
but by the time it got to me the details
were so vivid
I just didn't have like
the ability to like step back take a
deep breath
recalibrate and try to like think
through the information I was like oh
[ __ ] people are dead okay cancel this
turn the planes around get everybody
home how did that feel when you heard
that if someone in my team came to me
and said that I was putting on an event
and three people were dead already I
mean I just freaked out and said get
everybody out of here get everybody back
to Miami I know it's like that was your
response but
yeah I was just
I just didn't have the ability to like
okay like what's actually happening how
can we prevent this it was more of it's
like a quick knee-jerk all right send
everybody home it's over
one of the I think legendary moments
from the documentary which I know you've
been asked about and heard about before
is when
Andy King
says that he you called him and asked
him to suck a dick suck literally suck a
penis to have the water imported because
the Border agents had held it up
what's the truth in that situation like
did you ask him to suck a penis I've
heard so many variations of this story
and no he was never ordered to go suck a
guy's dick I literally put mouthwash in
he was gonna suck suck some dick he was
yeah that's news to me or I mean I
probably heard the story many times but
I think the the comment was ingest like
go suck this guy's dick get this water
like whatever it takes more of like you
know go suck up to him and get the water
released like do anything beyond paying
this guy right like you can't you can't
pay the Customs people so like go do
whatever it takes and just convince him
that our Festival is going to fail if
people can't drink water there's he's
obviously a gay man
and the Border agent was gay right I
think so yeah so the assertion of the
documentary was because he was gay you
had asked him to suck suck a dick if he
had to and he he took that literally so
he says he he went and put mouthwash in
and he headed down there fully prepared
to suck a dick I think that makes for a
good TV but yeah I certainly don't
recall it happening like that
unfortunately
crazy
do you still speak to him
um I've heard from him recently yeah so
are you in good terms I think it's a
good guy I think he tried his best to um
to help and unfortunately he was brought
on pretty late in like the process so he
wasn't there from the beginning but I
think obviously if he was willing to do
that he went above and beyond to you
listen if I try to make the festival
happen I'm sure yeah I wish him all the
best if I had a friend that was willing
to go to those links for me and I have
no friend that would do that for me
um I certainly would would stay in touch
and keep them on side yeah um in the
wake of fire Festival what happens you
eventually fly back to New York one of
the scenes that really did get me in the
documentary on an emotional level was
watching that wonderful Bohemian lady
talk about how she lost her life savings
um you know who I'm referring to right
uh I do know yeah yeah
um
how do you feel about that when you hear
that that some that locals you worked on
that hadn't been paid and then you know
they're in they're not living privileged
lives necessarily yeah
I mean it's terrible and the reality is
there are people who are owed there
and they're over for the last two weeks
of work before the festival I think
everybody's a little bit different but
getting them paid back
super important to me and trying to find
ways to start that process now
um I never met that lady before but no
her story is obviously super sad and you
know
um
I have heard from her through friends
recently and you know hope we can figure
out you know what is owed to everybody
and start making those steps there but
yeah unfortunately never met her but
hope to make right by her when you when
you leave the Bahamas off to that event
you come back to New York you come back
to a shitstorm yeah I mean the people
that have given you what 26 27 million
dollars in cash yeah
must be pretty mad for sure I I land
back on like the Sunday night after the
festival around midnight and then that
morning early the FBI is at my door
and I think like the initial investors
who got really mad thought that the
whole festival was a hoax and then I had
stolen the money and had it hidden
somewhere and it was like lying about
the entire thing
and so just like enter this Whirlwind of
of Hell your investors but basically
went to the FBI Yeah Yeah from from what
I understand yes what makes you what
gives you the understanding
basically I was called until it was
going to happen it's like you [ __ ] up
it's too late like here's what's gonna
happen now and and like I was totally
totally guilty and I would have gone to
jail like if no one made that phone call
I just made the process happen like the
process kicked off faster but once it
kicks off you know it's out of the out
of the hands of the investors and into
the justice system and I was black and
white guilty there was no gray area
there and you're one of your investors
called you and told you that if you
didn't give them X dollar yeah cash they
would
the exact lines were like we need this
amount of money or else you're going to
be on hanging handcuffs from the front
page of the Wall Street Journal and I
just like didn't have the money first of
all how much was it uh I don't want to
say because people will know the
investor probably is but seven figures
yeah yeah yeah more than a million
dollars more than one less than 10. so
um I didn't have it and then I was also
kind of like certainly naive in my
response at the time I just couldn't
fathom like that I was lying to
investors right like I knew I was trying
my best to make the festival work and
the media's initial like a line of
questioning and the guess line of
questioning as was all falling apart was
like this is a scam you didn't try to do
this so my reaction was like no I tried
I'm trying my best but I couldn't like
really understand the magnitude and the
gravity of the crimes I did commit
so I was still kind of fighting back I
go ahead and do anything wrong I tried
my best and then of course like I get
back and realize
oh [ __ ] I mean it didn't happen
overnight but here's what actually
happened
and yeah when you get when you get back
um the criminality doesn't stop though
does it no this is the bit honestly yeah
that really got me in the doctor because
I was like oh man you know some could
say young kid negligent inexperienced
his ambition was greater than his
execution told loads of Lies
at that point he learns his lesson but
then for the criminality and lying to
continue beyond that point with this NYC
VIP access where you start selling fake
tickets
give me the context why did that happen
yeah I've
many smart people officers have said the
same thing as you and
I was just caught in this process where
okay this investor he didn't threaten me
but the investor kind of gave me an
ultimatum
I blew him off and he was right he got
me arrested it's all about the money I
have to pay everybody back now all right
I'm gonna I'm gonna get him his money
and I wasn't like communicating with him
at this point but I'm gonna get him his
money I'm gonna pay everybody else back
and then this is all gonna go away and I
can solve this and I thought that the
proper response to a criminal process
was to solve the problem when the proper
response to criminal process is to sit
down shut the [ __ ] up and like accept
your punishment just just take it and
any other response just like the wrong
way to do it so you were on bail I was
on bail
and like
it was all about this desire like okay
now it's about the money let me pay
people back and back in the Magnesium
days like in the early fire days
Brands would essentially pay us to like
host these events for our members or to
invite members to random things and I
would always get invited to these like
charity events and the charity Gallows
and concerts and you know award shows
and whatever it may be I can get plus
one or plus two depending on it and I
thought like oh this is a great way to
make money I can just like you know call
these Brands back and ask for a favor
and get a few spots and sell these
tickets I just like was so stupid and
still wrong and obviously couldn't
fulfill what I was selling I'm like
[ __ ] up and it's kept me awake at
night just as much if not more in the
festival so we're on the same page there
so so you would Hamilton the Super Bowl
you would you would email people Coco
and tell them you had tickets take the
money and then when the event happened
I would scramble and try to get it and
sometimes I could but many times I
couldn't and you would keep that keep
that money I would refund it if the
event didn't happen but the problem was
I was just so sold out for events in the
future that I had no chance at actually
fulfilling that you know when my bell
got revoked and I got arrested it was
just like they lost their money and you
were doing were you doing this in the
magnesis day so I had a story about
Hamilton you said you had 200 tickets to
Hamilton
um and then when the event came near you
just like randomly scrambled on like
Ticket Hub or StubHub whatever it is and
bought the tickets last minute would go
and hand them out yeah so when in the
lying period leading up to the festival
I was trying to get money from
everywhere and definitely was trying to
get more money from Magnus to help pay
the bills as well
um
I was so stupid like was certainly
overselling access to magnesis events
but we ended up either buying the
tickets like at an inflated rate or
refunding everybody so I lost money
every single time you know it was crazy
like just so stupid
um your your ability to be so
comfortable with lying at that point in
your life
is terrifying yeah
it's one could almost say it's like
it's kind of it's kind of
I don't even say this but kind of lucky
that like
it was wasn't on an even bigger scale
and it wasn't like life or death stuff
that you were doing in terms of you know
what I mean because if you're that
comfortable lying to people
that could have been and you have the
sales ability clearly that could have
been a lot like how is your your
relationship with lying evolved in the
last couple of years since you've been
in jail and you've come out like
honestly how has it changed yeah
the lies at the time I think just the
craziest part was
how stupid it was from every level like
you know you work hard to build
relationships with friends with loved
ones with supporters and obviously as
soon as you allow them it's going to get
found out whether it's the next day or
in a year and five years they're gonna
believe that but you didn't seem to have
a belief I didn't be found out I always
knew in the back of my mind they're
going to find out but I convinced myself
that if I had made them if I gave them
what they want which I thought was
happiness and success it wouldn't have
mattered like that's where I went wrong
and it's like okay they're gonna know
that our Revenue wasn't this but I'm
gonna make the money and they're gonna
have fun so they're gonna love me still
I'm like it's so crazy to think about
now but like that was the thought
process and
that's like even like for the magnesium
stick it's like I If we oversold a
ticket for an event I was literally like
running around when I came back to New
York for a weekend like I'd go outside
Madison Square Garden and pay like four
times the price and make sure that
person was like happy in the moment not
realizing I just like lost a ton of
money in the deal and actually hurt
everybody else because we're losing
money on it so I was like so focused in
this like long-term goal or short-term
goal of happiness and success for
everybody around me and that's obviously
German due to insecurity and whatever
these desires are but yeah like that was
like my personal justification and crazy
but that's what it was
that day when the FBI come knocking yeah
you know this is before you put on bail
what is it like tell me because I'm
[ __ ] terrified of the FBI I've never
met him you know I'm just so scared of
them just from movies so tell me what
that's like scary as hell I think like
I wasn't defiant I was more like I tried
my best like that was my own like
internal like mentality like everybody
at that time was accusing me in the
Festival of all being fake and like
while I obviously made a million
management decisions the crime was like
in lying to investors right but
I just didn't comprehend yet like what
I'd really done and I didn't realize
that I was doing all these crimes for
this end goal making people successful
and even if it worked I still would have
gone to jail but it didn't work and I
was [ __ ] at least I couldn't
understand at that point what was
happening when did remorse show up and
and that realization of like guilt and
what you'd done when did that show up
it's hard to figure that out in your
story yeah I think like
the first day where I was like something
is really wrong was ad sentencing when
the judge said six years
and I kind of like looked back at the
faces of you know the friends and family
that were there
that was hard
and it's like I legitimately just hurt
when it was 30 people
in a way that's going to affect them not
just for four or five six years but for
20 years 30 years and it's never going
to go away
and I don't like that wasn't all the
lessons I learned in one day but that I
think was the start of what would take
another 18 months of being in jail to
really reflect on of like
wow like this is [ __ ] bad
genre was your co-founder um
did he throw you under the bus
I think he did what
most people would have done in that
situation so
which was well
yeah I think he certainly uh
I mean he's got a lot of talents right
but I don't think going going back to
jail was on his agenda and I was a
guilty one like he should not if all if
all things shook out fairly at the end I
don't think he should have gone to jail
he I don't think he committed any crimes
but like I think like most people they
quickly made it known like what I did
wrong and how I did it but yeah I mean I
feel bad for him I feel bad for
everybody else who was
who was trying their best they're trying
hard to to make things happen do you
still speak to him do you have a
relationship uh no if you spoke to him
since
you've been to jail or during jail or um
shortly after
um straight after getting arrested I
spoke with him like one time so this is
you know right when Bell started and
then didn't speak with him again and so
your your bell was revoked because while
you're on bail you started this NYC VIP
access correct and that violated your
bill conditions correct because you
weren't allowed to start a company or
you weren't allowed to all because I
wasn't allowed to keep lying right so
they found out you were lying there as
well and yeah that was it
so you go to jail yeah there's this
lawsuit where you were sued for 100
million dollars but you go to jail you
get six years in jail yes and you'll a
few things in in your sort of um your
sentencing you're not allowed to start
another company again what's the the
actual terminology there so I have an
SEC role the Securities Commission of
the US where I can't be an officer or
director of a public company for a life
public company yeah public company but
you can for private club private yeah
okay but for life which is you know
obviously if I'm in that position that's
a good problem to have but yeah people
are probably paid back at that point but
yeah you get found guilty of two counts
of wire fraud but then you also get
charged again for selling fake tickets
to events like the Met Gala Burning Man
and Coachella on top of that
which makes the sentence even worse
um for sure
so stupid
crazy
so it's almost like
it's ridiculous
just didn't know how to
didn't know how to say that I was wrong
and accept
that admission
you also got
you have to pay restitution yeah what is
restitution for anybody that doesn't
know
so it's basically wage garnishment
forever uh until I die or until
the people who are defrauded are paid
back
you have to so on all the money you make
for the rest of your life you have to
pay the investors who you lied to and
you raised 26 million from yes back a
percentage of the money exactly yes do
you know what that percentage is yeah uh
I think it changes based on your income
level and so it's been like three months
for me so far so I'm just like not
making
a ton of money right now I've I've made
literally made like eight restitution
payments so far in the first three and a
half months but I think the percentage
just kind of goes up and down based on
what you're earning so it's something I
guess I'll continue to learn about or
hopefully I learned about more uh asking
people to earn more
jail yeah
I said to you before we started
recording that one of my recurring
nightmares is going to yeah I like we're
able to voice it though because I had
the same one but I could never have told
anybody about that you know 10 years ago
of course yeah yeah
tell me about jail I hope I never I hope
I never find out yeah
I mean so much of me just want to like
put it in the past and never think about
it again but
it'll always be there
and the hardest part is the distance
it's like you're in timeout and you
can't like get consoled or can't like
love anybody
can't talk to your family and friends
and any Partners whatever else it may be
it's the forced distance
that is the hardest part
what does that do to you
I think like
when you're rendered useless and
Powerless for an extended period of time
it really messes with your psyche
and
I feel it every day now but I can only
imagine for the people who are there for
20 years 30 years you know significant
periods of time longer
than me like what it does I think this
system is designed to break down
ambition and creativity
and too like institutionalize you is the
word that is commonly used
and I think like that just kind of kills
your Humanity
and it kills your psyche and it just
makes you feel worthless
how has it changed you
and I I will go to the the positive
stuff but in a negative way can you see
symptoms of How It's had an adverse
impact on you yeah I think like and I
don't know no disrespected people who
have been through like way way worse and
there's many of them out there but like
having the I think from solitary
confinement having this
weird like almost like a PTSD paranoia
where I now know that there's someone
out there who can snap their fingers and
like shut my lights out right and
there's someone who could like wake up
and say we want him in a concrete box
for four years ten years and they can do
it and I can't stop it that's [ __ ]
scary I'm like that keeps me up at night
that's because you're on probation
probation yeah yeah exactly yep so it's
like you know you jaywalk and that's
enough where they send you back to jail
and they know you get to jail we're
gonna put you in solitary confinement
now I'm like
someone can snap their fingers and do it
and like that's
not mess with your message with your
head
I think I'm just like
I I'm before I was very quick to pull
the trigger but in both good and bad
ways and now I think I'm a little
trigger shy in a lot of aspects of life
and I worry that I won't get that like I
won't get that back in the good ways
because like every time I think like am
I going to make a decision where
someone's gonna construe this as me like
breaking a rule whether my tensions are
aren't and it's just scary and like
just knowing that I was so guilty in the
first place and deserved like everything
that happened but then also knowing that
it doesn't have to be that way and there
are people who you know weren't as
guilty as me who suffered as bad or
worse than me I think that fear has
always been there like when I was told
my release date from jail the two months
I had to wait after receiving the date
were the hardest time in jail like every
morning I'd like be shaking in bed like
waiting for him to call my name on the
last speaker to tell me it was a joke
and like I'm not going home
and I didn't believe I was going to go
home so for those 60 days it was like
I'm unbearable
and then like when the day comes I'm
waiting in like the cage like you're
already locked in a cage for him to
process you out I'm like okay the FBI is
going to show up and tell me it's all a
joke like I'm not getting out of here
and like it's just like the constant
like
disbelief that anything ever is gonna
happen again was the hardest part
and how long is your probation how long
have you got to live with that fear that
any decision you make concerns you three
years three years yeah
it's pretty long um
four years is a long time in jail yeah
you know it's it's a relatively small
number but if I think about what's
happened if I just go back four years in
my own life yeah to when I was 25 26.
better than me I was a different person
yeah crazy
crazy
and those are key years you went to jail
at 25 years old right yeah six years old
yeah now I'm 30. so it's like I'm
missing the latter half of your 20s is
definitely I mean deservedly obviously
but definitely
development years right I'm sure for
for most people
in terms of lasting memories that Joe
had on you and lasting impact take me to
what is the
what are the what is the worst thing
that happened in jail
that will stay with you for life the
worst thing you observed or so
um
I did two cents in solitary the first
one was three months second one was
seven months why the seven month stint
was because I tried to do a podcast over
the pay phone which is a terrible idea
to anybody listening well I didn't want
the competition so yeah shut that down
wait till Stephen invites you on but
um
they tried to send me to a terrorist
jail
and basically in retaliation for that
podcast
and they they put me in officially put
the paperwork in to send me to like a
terrorist facility and I've since gotten
out and like looked the facility up and
they're like there's like a list of the
inmates on like Wikipedia who are in
that jail and you know I'd be one of
like three non-terrorists there like
it's [ __ ] scary it's like I wanted a
podcast I was super boring of vanilla so
stupid to do it should not have done it
you can't do a podcast from jail it
doesn't make any sense but like
it all kind of feeds this concept where
there's like and I'm not a conspiracy
theorist believer at all but there's
someone who can snap their fingers and
your life is done and thankfully like
somewhere in the higher up chain outside
of the facility I was in like rejected
that and just sent me somewhere else but
that was a very real
possibility how are you trying to record
a book Austin Joe they have pay phones
um that you're able to make
I think like 20 15-minute calls every
month but you can do them all in like
one day so we have to wait 30 minutes if
you need to call so I had like a podcast
company set a podcast up where over the
course of two days I would call in every
half hour for a few hours a day and
record the podcast and they found out
when the episode was published the
trailer came out in like an hour or two
later they came and grabbed me and yeah
so that's it so that you can find them
yeah 10 months in total in solitary
component the worst part is not knowing
when it's going to end and they were
like [ __ ] with me like hey here's
where we're gonna send you and they
would like send me a program statement
it's called the CM the communication
management unit I like Marion Illinois
now here's where we're gonna send you
and I thought they were bluffing but
then they like two weeks later oh
McFarland they actually put your
paperwork in for they're like you're
[ __ ] like it's like the whole time and
no one's gonna tell me how long it was
gonna be or when it was going to end and
that was the hardest part like a
never-ending Saga they were taking
enjoyment out of [ __ ] with you oh of
course yeah I mean deserveably so if
your job is to you know work inside a
concrete bunker and like this [ __ ]
kid comes in I'm sure you know I don't
blame them for their actions
I heard you tell a story on the full
sign podcast about a young guy arriving
in jail yeah overhearing his
right yeah in Brooklyn yep
tell me about that
that was really really early on in my
jail stint when I had my bell revoked I
went to the Brooklyn Detention Center
here which ended up being there for
seven months net bus is certainly like
violent they have all kind of crimes and
levels of security people there it's
like all kind of mixed into one big like
fish tanky you know cell block
at that point I think I was like so
wide-eyed as to what was happening I
just couldn't really process
everybody's pain yeah at that point
because I was trying to like understand
my own pain
but yeah you see and hear things that
you don't think are real right and just
like didn't have the exposure to those
to that thankfully in my life before
that point what did you see in here in
that instance
expert people with nothing to lose who
are looking for attention or looking for
an outlet
taking advantage of others and it's it's
rough
it's just it's bad do you feel
uncomfortable talking about that
a little bit why I think like
there are obviously some great people in
prison who I met but there's
just as many bad people and it's like
bad people
surrounded by other bad people just kind
of creates it doesn't create anything
good
a story that I that I'm referring to is
I had you talk about quite recently was
that young man had come to the jail and
um you'd you'd heard him at night being
raped by another
more dominant inmate and you had to sit
in your cell and overhear that rain when
you saw him the next day he didn't tell
the police police guards because he
didn't want to
get hurt
um
so we're so like weird about that
situation was he was scared to tell the
police guards like what happened
but he had to move cells because like he
couldn't deal with it again so he found
a reason to move to a different cell
like in the same in the same building
that we were all in but the word got
around between the other inmates what
happened so the other inmates pressured
the guy who raped him to do something
about it basically and he went and like
took a razor blade and slashed the guy
the next day so it's like you're damned
if you do damn if you don't and like how
does that kid handle that situation like
if you tell on the guy in your entire
prison experience is going to be
terrible
if you don't tell it I'm gonna get raped
if you quasi-telling him you'll get
moved and then stabbed so it's like what
do you do and that's like it's just like
a wild
terrible situation how old was that
young young guy I think he was like a
year or two younger than me so this is
my first seven months so I was 25 or 26
so early to mid 20s
do those things I mean
do you have any like reoccurring like
nightmares about about that time is
there like almost a jail PTSD I think
from solitary like I was I was kind of
sheltered at that point because it was
so early I was the first that was the
first and only time I saw someone get
raped obviously had hurt stories later
on but never actually like I didn't see
it but like heard and like
heard the what was happening there and
heard like his blood like help me like
Scream the next morning when he was
getting slashed so that was that was
wild but I think I was it was so much
happening at that time I didn't fully
like take stock into like what had
happened so that happened a year or two
later I think it would have been more
like
difficult to comprehend but to the fact
that so much was going on at that point
it's like an overwhelming like emotions
like if you have a thousand loud sounds
blasting in your face and like one more
like horn plays in the corner you're not
gonna really register the horn as much
as if it was the only sound hitting you
at that time and you had therapy Joe uh
yeah they had like jail therapists yeah
did that help you at all in any way I
think so and I think it's all like it's
a journey right and you need to be the
one who kind of drives that car yourself
but
I think like
you know experienced people can push you
to start thinking about the right things
really while you've been inside over the
last five years the topic around mental
health is has really emerged in culture
what has your journey been like with
your own mental health have you
experienced we talked about anxiety
earlier at any point did you experience
what people call depression and the
symptoms of depression I don't know I
think like my the mental health Journey
started more out of angst I was in
solitary for it was my first stint there
and had a Wall Street Journal newspaper
come in and it was around the holiday
times like getting ready to do Christmas
like alone in the cell like you know
obviously super stressful and there was
like a whole back page spread in the
Wall Street Journal about dealing with
your anxiety in the wine store because
there are so many options and I'm like
these [ __ ] like do you know
what I would give to like be able to go
to a wine store like right now and like
how is this real so I think like my
initial like intro to like the invoke
mental health was like a bit of like
this is [ __ ] and then I think it
took a period of a couple years to start
like opening up
to the topic and the concept
have you opened up
to the topic not fully like I guess Like
For Better or Worse
you know I'm of the belief that
I committed the crime and like I could
have and should have stopped myself and
getting mental health like wouldn't have
stopped me from committing the crime and
I also believe that like I'm like
present to the point that
I certainly believe I know right from
wrong moving forward and if I commit a
crime in the future it's not going to be
because of like a mental health issue
it's because like I'm taking a shortcut
and you know copping out
you'll always try to get you off the
20-year prison sentence by saying that
you suffered from untreated bipolar
disorder the success reinforced his
grandiose and distorted sense that there
were no boundaries
bipolar disorder that's the defense that
your lawyers gave
is that true
I think like I am extremely flawed in a
lot of ways and I'm embarrassed about a
lot of things but I'm very embarrassed
about using like mental health as part
of my defense and I just don't believe
that that's an excuse for what I did so
I think that was that was a wrong
approach that I took there and like but
is it true
do you have bipolar disorder I don't
think I'm bipolar I'm sure I have mental
health like
concerns as many people do but yeah I
don't think I'm bipolar so do you think
that was your defense and you using that
as a way to try and load the sentence I
I yeah and I think I was stupid it was
wrong there's a quote from the the
prosecutor as well where they said that
the defendant is a Serial fraudster and
today is fraud like a circle has no end
Mr McFarland has been dishonest most of
the time
do you agree with that statement from
the judge
I think the magnitude of the lies that
led to that point
we're just so large and so bad
that it like it erased any good and so I
I think that was accurate at the time
that time inside you know you're getting
out
what's the plan you start writing books
in jail I had all of these things what's
the plan when you're looking forward at
your life with your ambition
what are you thinking I'm gonna get out
and I'm gonna do what the craziest thing
is that I never thought I would get out
and
I'd spend the time like planning things
and thinking about what I wanted to do
more as like a mental Escape but I was
just so convinced that it was never
going to end and obviously it sounds
silly
that's really been like the this like
aha moment like I am out of prison right
now
and I just like truly didn't think I
would be here
crazy I know but it was like the
paranoia of the situation really really
like convinced me that this was not
going to be over
and you've started a new company yeah
so I am out so I guess I have to do
something now so yeah you could have
done a lot of things yeah right you
could have gone in as you said people
told you to go get a job you could have
played it safe
you've started a company called pirate
yeah interesting name
there's a little bit of humor in there
yeah a little bit of a pun hopefully
people understand the self-deprecating
nature but yeah
and even the way that you're marketing
pirate we'll talk about what it is ETC
but even the mate you're very much
embracing what's happened and you'll I
remember seeing a video of the marketing
collateral and you say at the start of
it listen I've got a lot of people to
pay back here you're embracing yeah
what's happened was that a is that
strategy yeah I think like
beating around the bush
and hiding from the truth just makes no
sense right and like people are owed
their own money their own trust their
own an apology and not doing it and
avoiding it I think is worse
than saying it is what it is and here's
my step to make it right I'm like I
can't promise that pirate is going to be
worth anything one day I can't promise
it'll work or not work but I can promise
I'm gonna try are you are you really are
you sorry I'm super sorry who are you
sorry to
family friends first
supporters second
and then goes goes down the list from
there and what's the plan with pirate
yeah so is it Festival
not yet
um
for all like the really bad stuff I
think the one
crazy positive takeaway of solitary was
that
it gave me time to think
past tomorrow and if you kind of go back
to like those fire days with the Urgent
payment shoot I couldn't afford to think
past two o'clock you know let alone like
three years from now it's the benefit of
solitary was like read a lot of books
and really just like thought about
technology in a way that I didn't have
the luxury of due to my own mistakes of
doing before
plus like the reflection about like what
I suck at and what I'm good at so
Pirates like the combination of the time
to think seven years ahead and the time
to reflect on the areas that I need help
and the areas that I think I can succeed
at would you suck up
I went way too fast
I
turned down experts in certain areas
like thinking I knew more than them
I'm terrible managing finances I'm
terrible with Logistics but I'm good at
Building Products quickly and I'm good
at marketing I think most of all I'm
good at taking people and allowing them
to find Value in others that they might
have not found without me and then
inviting them and convincing them to go
try some experience they would never
have done without me and finding like
joy and success and ideas from those
experiences and connections and that's
what Pirate's really trying to do right
that's a parrot about tell me about
pirate if I'm if I've never heard of it
before and I'm a potential customer
what's what's the sales pitch so working
to partner with a really small like
Boutique Hotel in an adventurous Island
somewhere where we can host the content
creator from London like the
entrepreneur from New York the music
artist from LA on a permanent basis
connect them around all these Adventures
to go night diving to go Spearfish for
their own lobsters to make music you
know buy the bonfire at night
as many weekends out of the year as we
can but this time instead of trying to
bring like thousands of people there
we're rigging the area with these 360
cameras we're going to be live streaming
it to the rest of the world so all of
their fans no matter where they are can
watch what's actually happening and then
take advantage of these emerging
Technologies to own and even affect the
experience
so for example people online could chip
in a dollar and build a Beachside bar
and sell drinks their favorite artists
or like once I'm allowed to travel I can
be swimming at the reef and they can
decide to Chum the water and like the
local Captain who's like an amazing
character like
dump bait in the water and I think given
all the crazy sharks in the area people
would love to see the uh the results
alive of that but it's all about taking
people
on a manageable scale physically to
different places and then virtually
allowing them to connect with people
they never thought were possible and
partaking these experiences so for me I
would go out to some islands somewhere
yeah and then I'd be on the island
chilling and then my audience watching
can [ __ ] with me exactly or or like
impact your creative experience even as
well too so you could be like hosting a
bonfire chat or you can do a podcast
from a different Ireland location and
they can say hey we want you to do the
podcast from this island today with this
guest and ask these questions and they
can kind of get involved and help own
that experience
how are you gonna fund this yeah so like
right now it's doing everything and
anything like have a TV deal I've been
signing baseball cards I'm on Cameo like
literally like doing marketing for other
small startups and I think like things
have to grow and it's super super early
on but just trying to find any way to
you know get the revenue to do all this
you're gonna raise investment again I
don't know uh not tomorrow not this week
but you know in 6 12 18 months like I
have to kind of see what I'm allowed to
do and what I'm not allowed to do so
taking it step by step do you have this
kind of like because it's been such a
public failure and it's it's tarnished
by this like this subject of Lies liar
do every interaction you must have now
is there a party that knows that they
don't trust you
I think what's really like interesting
especially from the team standpoint is
I'm having an easier time finding like
team members and partners and like
employees whatever it is now and like
with having no money and having the
tarnish they did before I think for like
the 90 out of 100 people who just like
want to hate and like distance
themselves that almost inspires like the
10 of the people to really want to fight
for it and make something happen so I
almost have like deeper I think more
trusting relationships with my small
circle than I did before but obviously
I'm going to encounter you know millions
of people who are just gonna like say no
at first pass so
yeah when I heard you talk about pirate
recently a couple of weeks ago you
referenced the Bahamas now when you just
told me about pirate then yeah
you said some Island yeah I saw you on
full sense say you wanted to go back to
the Bahamas
yeah I I'd love to the Bahamas um we had
been working with a small local
development an island called Black Point
and we had a Super Connect connected
tight like local team that I had known
there for years that I called my dear
friends
um
a few weeks ago the Bahamas basically
announced that I wasn't allowed back
which was
super hard for me to hear I think the
reality of the situation is that there
are people in the Bahamas who are still
owed for their work and they need to be
paid back so before like any talks of
returning there happen like they need to
be paid back and I'd love to readdress
your relationship once that happens but
in the meantime pirate is the technology
we've built it is these experiences so
just like it's early I don't have the
answers yet but looking for other
locations to start testing what we've
been building who said who said in the
Bahamas you weren't allowed back the
government made a statement saying that
I'm not allowed back I think like some
media announced that I was doing a
festival there again which it was not
the situation and and I don't think I
ever announced that I hope I didn't but
I think that narrative was taken with
and run with to like this overall ban
which came out of left field for me what
did the statement say that I'm a
fugitive at the Bahamas
so if you go to the Bahamas they would
arrest you it sounds like it
uh I'm not aware of any charges that I
anytime or the past five years but once
again I think the reality is people who
worked hard for the fire Festival there
vendors uh contractors whatever it may
be are still owed and
you know if I can pay start paying 100 a
week whatever the number is like let's
figure that out and get that done
how are you doing
the stress is there
and
it's literally been three and a half
months right and it's like
how do I deal with this I think one of
the toughest things for me when I first
got out of jail I was in like a halfway
house program for a number of months and
the first people that kind of came to me
were people who I'd met in prison and
they were trying to essentially like you
know partner with me and get in close
and as I like learn more about those
people over time it's been more of like
separating myself
with from them and it's like building
and rebuilding with old friends and new
friends as well so
the human aspect took me some time and I
think I kind of like viewed the end of
my sentence as like a fresh start it's
like August 30th came I kind of like had
to separate from the people I'd been
around for just over four years at that
point and start reconnecting with old
friends and new people that's been a
challenge I think I've got a really
great small group right now but it's a
struggle to survive like I have no money
you know I'm trying to earn whoever I
can and just like get Consulting
marketing you know media jobs and just
doing my best but
it's not going to happen in six months
or nine months it's gonna take time are
you happy
I think I'm excited but also super
paranoid and nervous
so it's a mix and I feel like
I have like a good four to five years to
rebuild the foundation before
life is like copacetic again
and obviously coming in coming and doing
podcasts like this it can't be easy to
do this every [ __ ] day no you know
what I mean people like me calling you a
pathological life yeah yeah just reading
off all this stuff that you've done in
the past to be fair even harder than
every other one I've done so good for
you though we'll let you know what it is
um
it's not just that I feel like I have a
responsibility to it it's like
on this process you're on now there's
questions people want to ask and until
those questions are answered like
they're gonna remain yeah and in fact
for me I think Liberation for you is
like facing those tough questions and
answering them because eventually like
the truth is people are going to stop
asking them yeah like if they have those
answers so
um and you know I think it's worth me
saying as well I believe you should have
a chance I'm very much of the opinion
that like people like you that have done
wrong and that [ __ ] up and have held
their hands up and said I [ __ ] up I'm
wrong whether you're telling the truth
or not I don't know you you know I I
take you on your word but I believe that
if we have a society where people don't
get a second chance that is a worse
Society I spend a couple of two weeks
ago I went to a prison and spent pretty
much all day there really meeting
inmates and speaking to them and the
potential you know what I mean it really
did open my eyes because as you've
described I saw such unbelievable
potential crazy right I saw mistakes
that people had made in their lives and
then I saw a desperation to fix them and
to to get back out and be productive so
I think a society that has open up Open
Arms to to ex-offenders who have
committed certain lower level crimes I
think is a good site I'm not saying
yours is a low-level crime I'm not
passing judgment in your in your case I
think that's a better Society to live in
or else it's a waste of talent and you
know
so that's my stance on it now
do I do I believe everything you've said
in terms of like you'll never do it
again
I don't know
the scary part was you made a massive
mistake and then made another one you
know the fire Festival was a [ __ ]
very public [ __ ] show and then to then
scam people with the tickets I'm like
damn
I hope everything you've told me
told me is is the truth what message
would you want to send to the world like
all the people listening to this around
the world
what message do you want to send to them
I think the beauty that we all have in
some capacity is time right and it's a
patience too like I don't need anything
from anybody listening to this I just
hope that in 20 or 30 years we can look
back upon this conversation or snip it
to this conversation and said oh yeah
like oh this came true oh there's where
you messed up or there's where you did a
good job I think it's just like
documenting the journey and allowing
time to run its course and time Reveals
All Right
pirate where can we find pirate if you
want to go check it out we want to be
part of it where's where do we go to
check it out uh pirate.com p-y-r-t
orient.com yeah at piratebilly on social
great domain name yeah thank you cool
domain name yeah
he paid for that oh my God thanks to the
TV contract TV what's that just doing a
small like follow-on docu series about
like the attempt to build pirate nice
yeah you're ex I can tell you're excited
yeah are you are you nervous coming here
today
uh
not really I didn't know like I didn't
know how in depth we were going to go if
I'm glad I didn't really know because if
I knew the structure and the the
questions I don't think I could have
slept last night so like
glad I came in a little blind um I've
done three podcasts so far I did the
first one like maybe two weeks ago and
then I filmed the second one this
morning uh which is fun and then like I
guess I kind of came in thinking this
would be more jovial so I'm really
really glad I didn't know the depth of
this because I would have been super
nervous in the definitely not have slept
yesterday so of all the things I've
asked you what was the most
uncomfortable thing the thing where you
go ah insecurities drive like like the
why I think it's the most uncomfortable
because I don't have the answer
you're good and because you don't have
the answers yeah it still might be
running the show in the back room a
little bit right sure of course I'm
speaking from my own experience like I
talk I talk a lot about this podcast
whether I'm driven or whether I'm being
dragged by something and I've I've only
in the last couple of years started to
realize that I was being dragged by my
insecurities a lot of the time you know
my goals reflected that on Lamborghini
Ranger of a six pack yeah you know
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast everywhere the last guest yeah
asks a question for the next guest
without knowing who they're leaving it
for so they didn't realize that they
were leaving it for you okay interesting
question and I feel like I feel like I
might know the answer based on what
we've discussed
okay I'm gonna make a rule you can't
repeat something you've already said
here okay make a little more difficult
the question left for you not knowing
it's for you is what scares you the most
today
can't talk about probation
taking a shortcut
I think I have a propensity to go fast
and it's good in like Tech ways but it's
bad in life ways and there will be
opportunities that come from from the
media from podcasts from you know being
out of jail and it's not taking a
shortcut it's like don't get distracted
by the glittery lights and some
opportunity that ultimately represents a
shortcut
thank you Billy yeah thank you for being
thank you thank you for taking the
questions and thank you for being so
open and this is tough but I'm super
glad I did this and
the line of your questioning is amazing
so respect where it comes from and uh
yeah you're a master at this so thank
you thank you Billy hope you pay all the
restitution back hope you hope pirate
becomes a huge success I hope all the
lessons that you've learned over the
last 10 years God you've learned lessons
um all learned and they're replied and I
hope we can sit here someday five years
from now 10 years from now and talk
about
the opposite the success
um which is usually the conversation I
have with CEOs here okay the success
what you've built how you've done it um
and share all of those insights and
lessons
quick word from one of our sponsors I've
got a tip for all of you that will make
your virtual meeting experiences I think
10 times better
as some of you may know by now Blue
Jeans by Verizon offers seamless high
quality video conferencing but the
reason why I use blue jeans versus other
video conferencing tools is because of
immersion their tools make you feel more
connected to the employees or customers
you're trying to engage with and now
they're launching one of their biggest
feature enhancements to impact virtual
events so far called Blue Jean Studio I
actually used it the other day I did a
virtual event using the studio which I
think about 700 of you came to TV level
production quality all done by one
person with very little technical
experience on a laptop so if you've got
an event coming up and you're thinking
about doing it virtually check out blue
jean studio now let me know what you
think because I genuinely believe I know
this is an advert and I'm supposed to
say this but I genuinely believe it's
the best tool I've seen for doing really
immersive simple but high quality
production virtual events quick one as
you might know crafted are one of the
sponsors of this podcast and they make
really meaningful pieces of jewelry this
lion piece they've made I wear all the
time along with the little timepiece the
sand timer that I wear often and the
lion piece you might have seen Conor
McGregor has a similar piece which was
custom made for him for me it represents
courage and if you walk through my house
the house that I'm in right now if you
walk six feet in that direction you'll
see a huge lion portrait if you go
upstairs you'll see a lion portrait if
you look behind me on the Shelf near the
top there you'll see a line as well the
reason my house and my life is
surrounded by lions is because they
represent courage calmness and that
tenacity that I've applied to my
business success to my professional life
into everything in between for me the
line has always been an animal that can
be almost a bit of a contradiction they
are so loving and so caring of their own
and can be powerful and courageous when
necessary in order to achieve what they
want to achieve so if you like me are a
big fan of Courage bravery and ambition
while also being calm and composed check
out this line piece and let me know if
you get it
[Music]